[Music]
in ukrainian russian news
finally something seriously and everyone
want to talk about will smith slap and
all of us uh we forget and then everyone
takes down their ukrainian flag off of
their twitter and they put chris rock's
face up
like i'm with will
i'm with chris album cover i know it's
just a rock emoji yeah
rock emoji is good
so there's dude a russian billionaire
named roman abramovich
right i've heard of him that is a
billionaire name
so he's a russian billionaire named
roman abramovich sounds familiar because
he's actually the owner of the soccer
club chelsea fc
really that's why it had a ring to it
i knew it
um but he was at peace talks in kiev
ukraine earlier this month between
russia and ukraine and he was one of
three people that suffered a suspected
poisoning during the peace talk oh i
heard about that's why i heard about
this come on
come on what come on what i mean like
it just seems like obviously you're
gonna get [ __ ] poison in a peace talk
like obviously at the peace talk i saw
it coming dude what's your [ __ ] frat
party
you're not supposed to eat any food out
of pea stock you don't want a lunch
meeting at a pea stock you bring
nutrition bars but they've got his
favorite food
maybe
like a deserted building there was just
like a perfectly like a cake or cupcakes
just on like this gold tray yeah i mean
dude you're going you're going to peace
talks with a country that committed war
crimes of course they're gonna [ __ ]
spike your salad so uh the 55 year old
chelsea fc owner has now recovered but
he reportedly suffered sore eyes and
skin peeling that's poison bro well
that's ukrainian
psoriasis reported to have been targeted
so two ukrainian peace negotiators along
with this russian billionaire so who's
doing it
to both who done it you think they did
it to each other yeah we're going to
poison them no it was one of those we
are going to poison them one guy tried
to poison the other and then he tried to
do the switcheroos
and he forgot he was like which one is
it
i don't know
why don't you drink it
investigative website i said the
symptoms suffered by the trio were
consistent with poisoning with chemical
weapons though the dosage and type of
toxin indicated the attack most likely
was intended to scare rather than be
fatal
oh so it's okay so it's basically a
flash bang and a drink a flashbang
what's the message though it's like hey
you better chill out on your crane now
but it was both next time we'll kill you
yeah better use lotion more
that's a good feeling
[Laughter]
uh this uh investigated was a website is
named bellingcat they had tweeted out
and also had confirmed that the three
members of the delegation attending the
peace talks between ukraine and russia
on the night of the 3rd to 4th of march
2022 experienced symptoms consistent
with poisoning with chemical weapons one
of the victims russian entrepreneur
roman
they went on to state that the trio had
consumed nothing but chocolate and water
in the hours before the development of
symptoms oh that's what happened not
subside until the day after the attack
you think it was chocolate and water too
much chocolate chocolate chocolate so
the skin started peeling have you have
you ever ate so much halloween candy
that you're like that was a [ __ ]
thing i mean that happened that
somebody's like this is chemical warfare
your eyes are i have like eczema on my
arm so when my diet's bad i start to
peel oh yeah same here i'm a little like
a little dry skin is that like the
chocolate and water you've been uh
consuming yeah maybe he's allergic to
chocolate that happens to me with
hershey's hugs
really specifically just that candy yeah
[ __ ] me up man
three people specifically are allergic
to chocolate at the exact same peace
talks but chocolate and water dude
deadly combo dude imagine they're at
peace socks they're just sitting there
[ __ ] munching on chocolate
that's the official they got a whole box
they got a whole sampler box and like
just one more
i just like to imagine
peace talk poisoning is going a lot like
dumb and dumber where he's like once you
eat up first we'll tell you
about this piece why don't you take a
bite first
and we'll talk
i heard that's really good yeah i'll try
the chocolate
the piece will hit different after one
bite
chocolate bowl time
then it says that three members of the
negotiating team retreated to an
apartment in kiev later that night and
felt initial symptoms including eye and
skin inflammation and piercing pain in
the eyes later that night these symptoms
did not abate until the morning
the next day the group of negotiators
drove from kiev to the vive libri uh
on the way to poland and then istanbul
to continue informal negotiations with
the russian side a bellingham
investigator was asked to help provide
an examination by chemical weapons
specialists
based on remote and on-site examinations
the experts concluded that the symptoms
are most likely the result of
intentional poisoning with an undefined
chemical weapon
an alternative less likely hypothesis
was use of microwave
irradiation
symptoms gradually subsided in the
course of the following week so that's
been a thing because um one of our
embassies got attacked with a with a
microwave weapon and so there were
people who worked there who were
reporting those kinds of symptoms really
yeah what's a micro weapon it's like
popcorn it's like it gets activated it's
like in call of duty when you make the
barricade thing that goes
it's exactly the same
it's like a ray that like you know they
they use they they target an area with
it and then it's [ __ ] with your body
in some way they can just blow up
everyone's burritos at one time
and get really warm all the hot pockets
is warm
it's like a 5g tower you're at a
distance and you just [ __ ] radiate
the [ __ ] out of him yeah by like holding
up like a sausage
microwave
an open microwave but they confirmed
that like so it's it's a new thing that
we're going to start seeing so that's
probably what it is though i don't know
i'm just wondering if both sides got hit
did someone make a mistake yeah that's
what i'm going to eat yeah well if it's
the work of like some extremist that
wasn't included in the peace talk he
could have just been that [ __ ] bad at
it the saboteur because you know that
happens a lot you get left out of the
peace talks and you're like but i want
to be the peace no one will talk peace
now yeah
or i wonder if it's one of those things
where it's like uh
it's like you put a peace talk in play
but you're willing to sacrifice your own
guy because it's like we don't really
want peace we're just like that's true
expendable man dude they should do this
you know would be great if you did the
putin what if what if ukraine like just
ordered a [ __ ] ton of pizzas to the
kremlin
and made a paper every day [ __ ]
dominoes yeah putin's getting like 400
pizzas i didn't order these pizzas i
can't afford this you guys are going to
[ __ ] bankrupt keep doing this
i'm trying to pay for a [ __ ] war i
got to pay all these [ __ ] pizzas it's
all the donated crypto that purchases
pizzas to send to the kremlin
can you imagine dude putin pizza that's
what stops the water that'd be crazy
pizza stops the woman yeah
does putin have a wife
oh no he's got that one uh the olympic
gymnast gymnastics oh yeah a mistress
right but can you have a mistress if you
don't have a wife or that's the reason
is that just a girlfriend that's the
rumor that he's dating that russian uh
olympic uh medalist or whatever and has
two kids with the uh that chick but it's
it's like it's hidden yeah super hit is
that kind of thing like smiled upon out
there
like you have no wife
good for you yeah
you're mistress with no life wow
who are you cheating on all of russia
pretty cool man pretty cool because what
they should do is just they don't have
to do all this [ __ ] what they're doing
where they're like oh here's all these
sanctions and [ __ ] just sanctioned
creighton barrel dude and
the wife will be like yo what the [ __ ]
that's not the [ __ ] war i can't order
the any of my furniture like are you
[ __ ] kidding me right right
yeah dude
dude i'm telling you you end this
[ __ ] war right now immediately dude
great environment that's it maybe your
pure one imports after you cannot
we will not import
to or we will not export to russia and
then it'll be over it'll be on three
days
who can't handle that [ __ ] yeah that
just tells me that he doesn't have a
wife no he doesn't have a wife he's a
poor girlfriend yeah i can't get him
with anything
damn
didn't they say they were gonna bankrupt
him in 10 days
for the war by doing this and it's like
it's been 10 days oh dude but meanwhile
he's in eastern ukraine where they have
the second largest natural gas reserves
in all of europe so go figure they're
all acting like man putin's getting so
puned right now it's like oh cool he's
literally sitting on top of the second
largest [ __ ] natural gas reserve in
all of europe he's actually like
increasing russia's bread basket but
everyone's acting like he's getting
wrecked and it's just uh it's so funny
damn that sucks because that was one of
the things i was thinking about because
i was like what makes it worth it for
russia to go into ukraine and i was like
well ukraine has a lot of [ __ ]
resources um you know for crimea just
like crimea that's that was why he did
that and that's one of russia's biggest
ways of making money is through natural
gas through uh gasoline but how does our
media talk about it how does our media
talk about it putin's just a madman we
don't know why he's doing this it's
because he's a madman i know i hate that
[ __ ] so stu it's like no he's hitler
he's just crazy it's like well yeah he
is he is an [ __ ]
but he's trying to increase what yeah
russia's resources what the [ __ ] you
talking about playing all of us huh
right dude it's not even hard it's just
that our our you know the media just
just does whatever our government wants
so the government wants this this
talking point out there that he's just
it's a saddam hussein talking point once
again saddam is just a madman that's all
he is a and they tried it out with
different things and they don't like
democracies they hate their minds i hate
democracy they hate our freedoms yeah
okay but the funny thing is
our country is very tyrannical in many
ways so
i don't understand where they're talking
about this whole we need to protect
democracy because like ukraine's
actually way more corrupt than that's
what i keep it's like that it's not that
democratic like what are you talking
about the new york times was reporting
it was the most corrupt country on the
earth or second most like six years ago
wow six years ago but now they're like
if you say that it's russian
disinformation it's like guys come on
i mean there's a reason why they
couldn't join the eu and nato and like
all that it's because dude they did it's
too corrupt but did anybody watch
zolinski's netflix show so good it was
great i love him
yeah
they brought it back on crushing on him
too yeah yeah he's quite he's a big
hottie he's kind of hot he's a big time
honey i liked his dancing with the stars
thing the ukrainian dance [ __ ] dude
that's kind of awesome though he's like
pretty good [ __ ] acted as a president
became president
dude he's a he's a good guy and then
putin is a madman
[Music]
[Music]
you